hundreds of latino business leaders from
around the country are in las vegas yeah
their purpose is to exchange ideas help
each other kind of bounce back from the
copic pandemic christian kossera is
joining us live in studio with more on
how the local latin chamber of
commerce's national convention is
helping businesses grow christian well
brian and denise nevada has the sixth
highest number of latinos among u.s
states according to the u.s latin
chamber of commerce today they are
sending a strong message latinos are
ready to do business in the midst of a
pandemic we make the food homemade style
and fresh for the last six years the
salvador family have been living out
their dream of owning their own business
but this colombian restaurant near
spring mountain and jones like many
other small businesses were hit hard
when the pandemic started we struggled
at the beginning
however we we managed to stand
above surface and
we're still here our loyal clients
helped us out a lot like many they
focused on takeout and promoted heavily
on social media latino businesses have
been most affected by the pandemic
because they've been on the front lines
they're more direct services within
their businesses for the first time in
48 years the u.s hispanic chamber of
commerce is holding its national
convention in las vegas they're
connecting small businesses to tools and
resources to bounce back while sending a
clear message latinos are ready to do
business we're one out of every five
people living in this country five
million latino and latino owned
businesses an economic impact of 2.6
trillion dollars on our own the 65
million latinos in this country are the
seventh largest economy in the world
technology and medical are among some of
the fastest growing industries for
latinos a thread the salvador say they
are proud to be a part of we are part of
this community we
believe it is very important to stay
together
well cavazo says latinos are a very
resilient community because many small
businesses were already struggling to
get access to capital and loans before
the pandemic he is confident businesses
will bounce back christian casadas 8
news now